les aficionados prétendent qu'ils
veulent tous éviter la blessure et la
mort du torero mais il ne cesse
d'exploser son corps est pour moi la
corrida est condamnable du point de vue
de l'animal mais aussi du point de vue
de l'homme parce que j'ai très souvent
vu à des corridas
même si je ne suis pas allée très
souvent mais j'ai souvent vu des gens
attendre le moment et je pèse mes mots
et se créer cette espèce de petite
frayeur
le torero a fait un pas de côté est ce
que parce qu'il a prioris ce qui va pas
lever savez ça me fait penser un petit
peu à ces accidents
chaque fois qu'il ya un accident au bord
de la route les gens ont besoin d'aller
voir
alors effectivement les gens ont besoin
d'aller voir la mort et je pense que en
fait à travers la corrida c'est aussi ce
que beaucoup vont rechercher puis à une
deuxième chose je suis ni moins un
donc je connais bien nîmes je tenais
bien le public efficio nahd savait avant
d'aller à la messe maintenant à la
corrida et beaucoup de gens la plupart
des gens ne sont pas des aficionados ils
vont à la corrida parce qu'il faut y
aller tu as vu qu'il y avait la corrida
et elle était alliée comment tu crois
qu'elle est toujours avec intel dont je
crois que les plus réculés elle a
divorcé
voilà c'est ça aussi c'est une espèce de
snobisme dont il faut être très
conscient
[Musique]